♪ [music] ♪
In all of these sessions in corporate
finance, we've talked about value.
We've talked about maximizing value and
changing value, but we've never talked
about how to estimate the value of a
company. What is the value that you put
on a company? In these last few sessions,
that's the question we're going to try
to address. So, let's assume you're trying
to put a number on a company.
To get that number, there are three basic
ways you can estimate what a company
is worth. The first is to do what's
called an intrinsic valuation.
In an intrinsic valuation,
the value of an asset is the present value
of the expected cash flows in the asset.
You're trying to value business based
on its fundamental characteristics.
There's a second way you can attach a
number to a company.
You can do a relative valuation
or appraising. You know what you're trying
to do here? You're trying to attach a
number to a company based on how similar
companies are being priced out there.
There's a third way you can
attach a number to a company.
If the cash flows on a company
or a business are contingent
on something happening,
you could actually apply option pricing
to put a number on a company. Generically,
these are the only three ways you can
attach numbers to companies,
an intrinsic valuation, appraising,
or real options. I'm going to start with
the intrinsic valuation because it ties
most closely to what we've been
talking about in corporate finance.
In an intrinsic valuation,
the value of a company is the present
value of its expected cash flows over its
lifetime. Well, most of you who've seen
these valuations might think of them as
spreadsheets, and cash flows,
and discount rates. When I look at a
discounted cash flow valuation or
an intrinsic valuation,
I'm seeing answers to four questions I
have about any company I analyze.
Here's the first question.
What are my cash flows from existing
assets? Remember, your company has been
around awhile. It's already made
investments. The cash flows from those
investments become the starting point
for estimating intrinsic value.
That's why we look at last year's
financials, the income you made,
the cash flows you made.
The second question I'm trying to answer
is what is the value of growth on this
company? Notice how I've phrased
that question. What is the value of
growth? I might ask you what your growth
rate was, and here's why.
Growth can create value.
It can do nothing for value.
It can destroy value.
The value of growth is a trade-off.
The good side of growth is that it allows
your earnings to grow over time.
The earnings become larger.
The bad side of growth is you have to
reinvest to create that growth.
The net effect is what determines the
value of growth. What are your cash flows
from existing assets?
What's the value of growth?
The third question I've to ask is
how risky are your cash flows?
And the place that shows up in your
discounted cash flow valuation is in the
discount rate. So, your cash flows from
existing assets show up in your base
year numbers. The value of growth shows up
in the growth rate you use and the
reinvestment you put in.
The risk shows up in the discount rate.
There is one final question I need to ask
and get answer to value your company.
When I ask you, "When is your company
going to become a mature company?"
You're saying, "What's a mature company?"
A mature company is one that grows at a
rate less than or equal to the economy.
And here's why I need to know the answer
to that question. In theory,
a publicly traded company can keep
growing forever. I can't estimate cash
flows forever. But if your cash flows
start to grow at a constant rate forever,
there's a mathematical trick I can use
to compute the value of your cash flows in
one step . And most of us who have done
discounted cash flow valuation
have seen this trick play out as a
terminal value. But to you use that trick,
you got to assume that your cash flows
grow at a constant rate forever.
That's why I asked you when will your
company be a mature company.
Because for your cash flows to grow at a
constant rate forever,
that growth rate has to be less than or
equal to the economy. So,
when you think about valuation,
think about the answers to those four
questions. What are your cash flows
from existing assets?
What's the value of growth?
How risky are these cash flows?
When will my company be a mature company?
So, let's set the table.
When you sit down to value a business,
there are two ways you can
approach valuation. In the first,
you wear blinders. All you care about
are the equity investors.
You try to value just the equity in the
business. What does that mean?
You focus on the cash flows equity
investors get from the business and you
discount those cash flows back at the rate
of return that equity investors demand
for investing in the business.
In corporate finance terminology,
you discount your cash flows
to equity at your cost of equity,
you end up with the value of equity.
This strictest version as a model,
your argument is the only cash flow that I
get as an equity investor from a publicly
traded firm is dividends.
The divided discount model is a special
case of an equity valuation model.
In our discussion of dividends,
we talked about potential dividends,
free cash flow to equity.
Think of that as the more expensive
version of an equity valuation model.
In both cases, you're looking at cash
flows to equity discounting at the cost
of equity. There is another way
you can approach valuation.
Rather than the equity-focus,
you can try to value the entire business.
What does that mean?
You look at the collective cash flow that
equity investors and lenders get from the
company. Equity investors get their cash
flows to equity. Lenders get interest
payments and principal payments.
That collective cash flows called
free cash flow to the firm.
You discount that cash flow to weighted
average of the cost of equity and the cost
of debt which is the cost of capital.
What you get as a present value is the
value of the firm. You've got to make
the decision early in the process.
You have to decide when you sit down to do
valuation, are you valuing just the equity
or are you valuing an entire business?
Now, you might wonder,
"How do I make that choice?"
I'll give you a simple rule.
When you cannot estimate free cash flows
to equity for whatever reason,
you might have to focus on just dividends.
All too often, that was what analysts used
to do when they valued banks. They'd say,
"Look, we cannot estimate free cash flow
to equity. We're just going to discount
dividends." If you can't estimate
cash flows, then the choice becomes more
complex because you can do cash flow
to the firm or cash flow to equity.
Here's the simple rule that I adopt.
If you have a company with changing debt
ratios over time, estimating cash flow
to equity becomes a pain because you got
to estimate how much debt gets repaid,
how much debt gets taken on. So,
when you have shifting, unstable,
or unpredictable debt ratios,
you should be valuing the entire firm.
If you have a predictable debt ratio
that's not going to change over time,
then you can do an equity valuation.
Nine out of 10 discounted cash flow
valuations that I do are
firm valuations because it's very
difficult to find a firm with a debt ratio
you have today is the debt ratio that
you're going to have forever. So,
let's assume you've made that choice,
equity or firm. Let's go back to the
notion of valuation. Because as I said,
doing valuation requires inputs,
and the way you estimate numbers for these
inputs will depend on whether you took
the equity route or the business route.
So, let's start with the first question.
What are my cash flows
from existing investments?
If you're valuing the entire business,
that cash flow has to be a pre-debt cash
flow, a cash flow before debt payments.
If you're valuing equity,
it's going to be a post-debt cash flow.
When I ask you what the growth
in these earnings are going to be?
If you're doing an equity valuation,
your growth has to be in equity earnings,
net income or earnings per share.
If you're valuing the entire business,
it's got to be on operating income.
When I ask you, "How risky are these
cash flows?" The discount rate you're
going to give me if you're doing an equity
valuation is the cost of equity,
whereas if I'm valuing the entire firm,
it's going to be the cost of capital.
When your firm will be a mature firm will
be answered exactly the same way
with both equity and firm valuation.
But when you discount cash flows
to equity at the cost of equity,
you've valued just the equity.
Whereas when you discount cash flows
to the firm at the cost of capital,
you've valued the operating assets of the
company and you might have more work to do
before you get from there to the value
of equity. We'll come back and talk about
those extra steps you need to take.
But for the moment, this should give you
a broad view of how to approach valuation.
Now, as you've done this class,
you probably have wondered whether
you can value your own company.
Well, we've started on that process by
looking at the two different ways
you can approach valuation.
You could value just the equity in your
company or value the entire business.
In the next session or two,
we're going to talk about how to get
the cash flows and discount rates.
And you're going to see much of the work
you need to do, you've already done.
♪ [music] ♪